your personality literally is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel and how you think how you act and
how you feel is your personality and
your personality is intimately connected
to your personal reality your life so
then if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you gotta start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you gotta
start noticing how you act how you speak
you gotta pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so when you begin to
make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
inspire new thoughts and that's called
evolution want to be happy build a life
not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can destroy your
negative thoughts
enjoy
so how do we get stuck
it's really simple the stronger the
emotion you feel from some event in your
life be it a betrayal or a trauma or
whatever the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you pay attention
to the cause outside of you so the brain
takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory
so we create long-term memories from
strong emotional events okay so is that
true i just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to you the stronger of a hold it
has over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on for
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electromagnetic
magnetic field around the person's body
that's energy to heal that's energy to
create a new future with right and then
if you didn't want to lower the volume
to the emotion then just take your
attention off the person and every time
you take your attention off the person
if you became conscious of that you
wouldn't feel the emotion now the body
though
has been addicted to that emotion right
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
the body says well i've been conditioned
this way and conditioning is based on
the past so when the body feels the the
lack of that emotion just like a drug
addict it says hey you're off schedule
here so now the body starts influencing
the mind to think about experiences that
are embossed in the brain that are based
on that emotion so the emotion now is
causing you to think in the past if we
teach a person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you going to do sooner
or later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude as an example yes the
person says well i can't feel gratitude
and i say absolutely you can because you
don't practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny you've got to maintain
that modified state of mind and body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready
because something weird or unusual some
synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well i was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life rule
number two take control with mel robbins
if you've been sitting around waiting
for somebody to discover you to pick you
to save you to rescue to give you your
shot it's not happening
like at some point you got to wake up
and realize when you're 18 and you're
out of that house you have to parent
yourself
your life is your responsibility and as
a woman one of the things that i found
to be
extraordinarily transformational is when
i stopped in a very traditional sense
looking to my partner to be responsible
for providing
for me
providing financially providing the
support providing when i realized
wait a minute it starts with me
i have to be
able to figure out how to make myself
happy that's by the way the secret to a
happy relationship marry somebody who's
happy and work on your own happiness
preach
and so when you stop outsourcing
your happiness your validation your
support all of it and you bring it back
in
and you get responsible for it it sounds
scary it's so
liberating because you could do anything
when you're responsible when you're the
driver of your life when you're not
looking out to anybody else to fix it
for you can you ask for help of course
but the buck stops with you
you're the one that has to do the work
you're the one who has to push your own
ass you're the one who has to figure out
what makes you happy you're the one who
has to figure out and become self-aware
about what you need and then you're the
one that has to
find whatever it is the courage or being
humble enough to ask for help
even if it's asking for help
from the biggest ally that you have
which is the person staring back at you
in the mirror every damn morning
yeah i don't know why people aren't more
obsessed with their goals it's like
if my goals demand that i ask for help
then i'm going to ask for help like i'm
not even going to let anything else get
in the way i'm just so obsessed with if
my goal is exciting and honorable then i
should actually want to achieve it and
therefore whatever it is that i need to
do so tom this is why
and this comes back to what makes has
made me really sad and
deeply moved by the kinds of things that
people are sharing
most people aren't obsessed with their
goals because they don't believe they're
worthy of them
it's easy to dream about what you want
but in between where you are and what
you want there's a tremendous amount of
stuff you got to change and do
and if you have
a lot of trauma in your background or
you were raised by somebody who beat the
[ __ ] out of you or told you you were a
piece of or if you've had to deal with
microaggressions or racist
discriminatory systematic crap your
entire life
you have been given the message over and
over and over even though it's not true
that you don't deserve it that there's
something wrong with you
and if you don't
at some point
be defiant against what the world or
your caregivers or your past experience
has pounded into your brain incorrectly
unfairly
you will forever be stuck with that
story
you are not responsible for what
happened to you
you survived what happened to you
but you do have a responsibility
to heal yourself and to do the work to
change so that you can be the happy
fulfilled person that you were born to
be
yeah that's really powerful because it's
the only thing that works and
you know thinking about
so many people have just immense things
that have happened that have been unfair
and as you said they didn't do anything
to deserve it but now what
now you're there you've got the trauma
and no one can heal it for you it's
there's a name for it i think it's
called the pedestrian problem it's like
imagine that you get hit by a car and
the driver was drunk and
let's say that the driver was bill gates
and let's say that
you win a settlement
but if
the damage that happened to your body
can't be fixed
with all the money in the world and you
just have to do physical therapy then
it's like
even though it is unfair that you have
to do the physical therapy you there is
no amount of money that you can throw at
it that will stop you from having to
suffer to build yourself back up
and i think a lot of people either fall
prey to trap number one which is they
don't think they're worthy or they fall
prey to trap number two which is it's so
unfair they just don't take action right
but they're nonetheless in the situation
that they're in and if the whole punch
line to life is neurochemistry and
feeling joyful and you know being um
excited about who you are when you're by
yourself then it's like well you have to
do the work even if it isn't fair and
that time especially if it isn't
because there's two
kinds of
prisons that you can sentence yourself
to or be sentenced to right one is all
the physical [ __ ] you're talking about
the circumstances of your life the
circumstances of your body the
circumstances that are unfair and then
there is the mental prison and that's
the one you're in control of
so people can do all kinds of [ __ ] to
you
and you can be born into situations that
are not uh
fair they're not safe they're cruel
it's unfair you didn't deserve it
but the real power that you always have
is
how you react to it mentally i'm not
saying put lipstick on a pig and ignore
the very real problems you're saying
you're you're facing
i'm saying
it begins with your mental attitude
about your own ability to face it
and to
survive it and to move past it
that's what i'm saying
because without that like let's go back
to the woman in the domestic violence
shelter who's had this beaten out of her
by partners who has immense emotional
trauma stored in her nervous system
stored in the neurochemistry of her
brain she has a extraordinary amount of
hurdles to get through in her life to
heal to be safe to break patterns that
are associated with the trauma that
she's experienced as a child the trauma
that she experienced in romantic
relationships the physical abuse she has
issues related to poverty
can a human being
survive those things and change of
course they can
it begins though
with the belief that you can
and so when i come back to this moment
every single morning
you can have nothing
and you can still have your own back
you can have tremendous
problems and very real obstacles that
you're facing
and you can have a mindset that says
through my efforts
my attitude i can have an impact
on the situation that i'm in
that's the power that i have
i can ask for help because i believe i
deserve it
i can
seek therapy because i believe
i should heal because i deserve that
i can seek information from shows like
impact theory about how to break trauma
patterns about how to regulate my
nervous system because i believe
i am worthy of that when i raise my hand
in the mirror i'm basically saying
off to these people that hurt me because
i believe that i deserve better
that's where it begins begins with you
self-confidence
self-love
self-esteem
self-reliance
self-awareness it all has the same self
you have to
give yourself
those things you want validation give it
to yourself you want to be cheered for
give it to yourself if you want to feel
supported in life
start by giving those things to yourself
because
the most important relationship that you
have
is the one you have with yourself and
you work on it the least
it's the foundation of every
relationship you have
and
so i believe that there are simple
things you can do from looking at hearts
which doesn't solve your problems it
proves to you that it's possible to
change the way your brain works
that's why i want you to do it it's not
gonna take away poverty it's not gonna
make you lose a hundred pounds it's
gonna prove to you that
you do
have power
over the way your mind works and when
you get crafty about training your brain
you can do really cool [ __ ]
and when your attitude is optimistic
based on research we know that you will
work harder and keep going because you
believe that it makes a difference
it begins with these simple things rule
number three shift to a positive
attitude with lewis howes this is
something i learned in sports early on
is to have a positive attitude when
things go bad now
the world is filled with a lot of
different negativity drama stress and
sometimes it's hard not to fall victim
to joining in on the negativity this is
one of the reasons why
my father growing up would not let us
watch the news he would not let us watch
commercials that talked about a lot of
harmful things or the news because he
didn't want us to be susceptible to
hearing about things that maybe are
happening in a micro level that are
blown out of proportion that seem like
it's happening all over the world was
really only happening in a small level
he didn't want us to emphasize on all
this negative energy in this negative
attitude so he eliminated those thoughts
from our mind to support us in the
positive in sports as well i would also
have coaches that you know things
wouldn't always go our way and i used to
be so negative i used to be so reactive
when i missed a shot when i dropped the
ball
when i messed up when something that i
did was wrong or was a mistake i used to
beat myself up so much or when we'd lose
i was such a sore loser i had such a bad
negative attitude
and our coaches over the years would
really teach me like that isn't helping
you that isn't supporting you or your
teammates around you but having a
positive attitude when things go wrong
will lift your teammates up will lift
you up to help you improve for the next
play in the next moment it's really all
about having that positive attitude
because the negative doesn't usually
serve us for anything ever there are
times absolutely to speak up and be a
stand for when bad things are happening
to you or happening to other people or
around you but that's not what i'm
talking about i'm not talking about that
specific moment in time i'm talking
about spending hours of your day
thinking about yourself negatively and
thinking about the world negatively
around you just ruminating on how
negative everything is that prevents you
from showing up as the best version of
yourself and i believe you're robbing
yourself and your loved ones and the
world of your gifts and who you truly
are when you sit in that negative state
so when i began to shift
into having a positive attitude it
really helped me in every area of my
life and negative things or things that
i don't like happen around me all the
time but it's a practice even today
and when i'm hit with these adversities
or these obstacles i try to ask myself
how could it possibly serve me in the
future
or if it's worth putting so much energy
into it around a negative attitude is it
really worth it
is it helping me and my health is it
helping me my joy and my love for others
and my love for myself by holding on to
this negative energy it's usually not
worth the energy so why do we do it so
frequently
you know there's this book called don't
sweat the small stuff
because it's all small stuff you know
obviously there's adversity and there's
challenges but when you can have the
attitude around it it really shifts your
life and the people around you so you've
got to do the work to develop that
awareness to realize that for yourself
this isn't easy this took me a long time
and having a positive attitude is
in my opinion one of the most important
things to manifesting to attracting to
feeling better about yourself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four move forward with
tom bilyeu my self-limiting beliefs stem
from childhood trauma what suggestions
do you have that might help me overcome
them
okay so this unfortunately is something
that comes up a lot and one i just want
you to know trust me when i say you were
not alone so many people are struggling
with childhood trauma and
one i want to say that having a
professional therapist work with you on
this is probably going to be the right
answer without knowing exactly what it
is you're struggling with becomes very
hard to help somebody deal with it but i
can tell you that a lot of times what
ends up happening is people end up
feeling that their self-worth is
diminished and they don't believe that
they're worth um
getting rid of the limiting beliefs and
they think that they are damaged or
um compromised in some way and so one
recognizing that that just is not true
and that you absolutely are worth it and
that the only thing that makes sense is
to adopt one of the beliefs that really
changed my life which is that the only
thing that makes sense is to only do and
believe that which moves you towards
your goals so even if
it were true
that you are worth less
it doesn't help you get towards your
goal to believe that and if we're only
going to do that which moves us towards
our goals then immediately when we begin
thinking that we're worth less we don't
have to convince ourselves that it isn't
true we only need to realize it doesn't
move us towards our goals and since we
only do that which moves us towards our
goals we're going to pattern interrupt
immediately the second we start playing
that loop because we've got to break the
habit of thinking that about ourselves
so we're going to pattern interrupt that
we don't allow ourselves to think that
anymore it's done it's just not an
effective strategy
and that was a big deal for me because
the thing that i was struggling with was
i'm not smart enough to pull this off
and
by believing that then i didn't try and
as long as i didn't try i was never
going to fail which of course was the
thing i was trying to protect myself
from but i was also never going to
succeed
and so finally what i had to realize was
because my behaviors were being dictated
by my beliefs i could not allow myself
to believe something even if i was
convinced it was true
i couldn't allow myself to believe it
because it would stop me from taking the
behaviors that would lead me
to learning growing getting better and
moving forward and so
you
it's not that easy childhood trauma is
wicked it is so pernicious it gets
inside your mind and it won't let go and
depending on how early in childhood
there is a lot of brain development
around that trauma but i'm just saying
one of the things that we're going to
have to do outside of therapy is begin
to pattern interrupt that to not allow
yourself to repeat those negative
stories about yourself
and
to only do and believe that which moves
you towards your goals so if loving
yourself is going to move you towards
your goals then we're going to do it
even if you don't think that you're
worth it if pushing to grow and get
better is going to move you towards your
goals then we're going to do it even if
it doesn't feel like you deserve it
you have to let go of that in order to
get to your goals and now as long as
your goal is exciting and honorable why
would you ever want to do something to
hold you back if you're doing something
that elevates yourself and other people
why would you want to stop yourself from
doing that even if you deserve to be
punished or whatever it is that you
think about yourself because of what
happened in the past
it doesn't make sense
free yourself from that
allow yourself to contribute to yourself
and others contribute as big and
aggressively as you want as you possibly
can
and by continuing to believe
that you're not worth it you won't be
able to do that you won't be able to
turn your potential into skill set you
won't be able to get into that passion
loop where you're able to learn
something and gain mastery and add value
to other people's lives and get that
positive feedback from them you're so
busy living in the past
that you forget
that there's an entire future waiting
for you
but you have to let go of the past
before you can move forward now i don't
want any of that to sound right again i
understand how difficult this is and i
highly encourage you to get professional
help there is nothing wrong with that in
fact it's amazing it's beautiful that
you would think enough of yourself to go
and put the time and the energy into
getting better and you can get better
but you're going to have to put in the
work rule number five strengthen your
mind with dr rahul jondial this is not
to lose weight it's what nutrients to
put inside you where if you have a
thousand people here you have a thousand
people here and for 20 years they eat
differently
what are the numbers of people with
dementia all other things being equal it
essentially says
uh it doesn't have to be mediterranean
it just has to be
plants like as i might tell my kids
plants which is
you know fruit or salad it doesn't have
to be just salad you know yogurt nuts
lean meats like you know chicken and
salmon what is it that salmon omega-3s
it's the only thing in our literature
that we know is an is
a nutritional component in food
that is good for brain health and
the omega-3s are unique type of fat
that are
you know the brain is an extremely fatty
organ and so it needs to it needs to
have those fats omega-3s
are the only things nutritionally that i
would say is you could supplement or
actually add salmon in a couple times a
week so that's the mind diet twist on
the heart diet by adding a little bit
more emphasis on salmon what you can
have is a lot of fried processed food
and if you have
a cheat day or whatever you have a
burger it doesn't negate what you've
done i think that's the hardest thing
about dieting for people they feel like
the shift has to be complete and
religious and to me it's more glacial
because the benefits will also take
decades to accrue you know that's my
that's my perspe you know
those are the nutrients that are best
for the brain
you talked about intermittent fasting in
the book what do you think about that
what is its impact on the mind longevity
um what's its point so if you want to
kick the mind diet into next year
and you're thinking i don't want to just
stave off
brain degeneration right like what if
you wanted to work on focus and
cognition these things are harder to
test but when you go into the big
neuroscience journals
they speak about intermittent fasting
and the best way i can explain it is
your brain's a hybrid vehicle
it grew it evolved through through
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years of lots of food scarcity
you didn't eat all the time
and so it's got a backup mechanism
called ketones so after 16 hours
if you don't put glucose in
and the liver is done
releasing the glucose it's held onto
through glycogen reserves then it'll
start burning fat
it'll clip off those oxygens and
hydrogens and they'll make ketones out
of it
intermittent fasting can also help you
lose weight i think that's why most
people are interested in it but it's the
way the brain prefers to get its fuel
source and it's based on a diet
lessons about dieting learn through
controlling
epilepsy and seizures in kids
in areas where there's no medicine
so i was in ukraine
and
when they don't have medicine or a type
of seizure seizure the abnormal
electrical activity of the brain just
like an arrhythmia would be an abnormal
electrical activity of the heart
they would just feed them all fat diet
you could smell it in the hospitals so
something about an all-fat diet
forcing you into just using ketones
now intermittent fasting is back and
forth glucose and then ketones glucose
and then ketones but for kids if you
just get them almost nearly all ketone
as the source that goes up to the brain
through an all-fat diet
their
seizure rates
go down you know so that's proof
that food changes mind
because the mind is the electricity
sparking through that flesh food
will change the electricity detectable
measurable electricity in your brain
food affects mind food affects brain
with that premise
we can talk about okay mind diet will
hold off
dementia and intermittent fasting might
make you feel like you've had a cup of
coffee once you get a rhythm out it's
not going to make you smarter but it'll
bring you to your most focused to bring
you to your most attentive it's not oh
i'm intermittent fasting and now i can
do physics it's
it's not like that it's
your personal best and then the habits
you demonstrate to your family by trying
to be at your personal best and then
your kids see that and your friends see
that i think that's how you impact
generation change is to have
uh capable people demonstrate hey it's
not hard and this is the best we can do
for ourselves number six keep your brain
healthy with dr daniel amen when i saw
my brain i'm like ouch this can be
better and so how do you make it better
well the second thing is you avoid
anything that hurts it and i have a
mnemonic we can talk about called bright
minds
it's if you want to keep your brain
healthy you have to prevent or treat the
11 major risk factors that steal your
mind yeah so brain envy got care avoid
things that hurt it
do things that help it and so what what
did we learn that exercise boosts blood
flow to the brain not believing every
stupid thing you think calms the anxiety
centers in the brain things like omega-3
fatty acids get your gut right because
your gut makes most of the
neurotransmitters in your body well the
little tiny habit for brain health is
before you go to make any decision you
ask yourself this is good for my brain
or bad for it and if you love yourself
because it's never about should as soon
as you think you should do something you
won't do it
just because we're all four years old in
our head and rebellious it's
you
answer the question in a positive way
because you love yourself because you
love
yourself your wife your life your
mission um
that's why you do the right thing
because too often people go well i can't
have this and i can't have that and as
soon as you get into that deprivation
mindset
it's not going to work even if you've
been bad to your brain you can make it
better and i can prove it
i've spoken to my audience about it
before but the thing that led me to you
was
massive anxiety that seemed to be
getting worse by the day and one of the
things that helped me was crushing the
ants the automatic negative thoughts and
becoming a pattern interrupt and
stopping that walk people through some
of the things that
aren't necessarily because we'll get
into diet but that aren't diet related
that are really just
the way that they allow themselves to
think whether it's the brain getting
stuck and looping around um repetitive
negative things whether it's negative
thoughts that they never interrupt like
what are those things that really
cause people problems that they may not
even be aware of we have a brain health
assessment online people go to
brainhealthassessment.com and go which
of the 16 brain types do you have
so let me take just a step back and i'll
answer that question whenever i see
someone so if you came to see me
i'm always thinking about the four
circles of your life so i'm thinking
about your biology so with anxiety
my first thought is areas in your
emotional brain just working too hard
and so it's driving that anxiety so
what's the biology what's the psychology
which is how do you think and the
environment that you grew up in
what's the social circle um because if
you're around a lot of
irritated angry negative people you're
more likely to be anxious
and what's this spiritual circle um why
do you care why you're on the planet
what's your deepest sense of meaning and
purpose so i'm always thinking
biopsychosocial
spiritual and that way i end up helping
whole people not just oh you're anxious
to examines because that's the
quick answer
that if you go to
kaiser for example and
i just hired a doctor from kaiser and he
saw 25 patients a day so the 25 patient
a day answer is xanax is let me give you
a benzo
and the problem with it is once you
start it it's insidious it changes your
brain to need it in order to feel normal
and so i'm like so how else can we quell
your anxiety so there's some simple
supplements like gaba or one of my
favorites magnesium that can be really
helpful
but the psychological one there was one
day i
was at work and i saw four suicidal
patients and that's hard for me and then
i saw two couples who hated each other
and two teenagers who ran away from home
and so at the end of the day i was worn
out and i came home to an ant
infestation in my house
and
i'm cleaning up thousands of ants and
i'm like
and then it just hit me and
automatic negative thoughts
my patients are infested
and the next day i went to work with a
can of ant spray and i put it on my
coffee table and i'm like we need to
help you get rid of these things that
are infesting your mind and they like
that it was just something they could
grab onto so here's the exercise
whenever you feel
sad
or mad or nervous or out of control i
just want you to write down what you're
thinking
and ask yourself if it's true rule
number seven change your thinking
pattern with marissa peer here's the
thing we always focus on the feeling not
the thought yeah but i love that you say
everything stems from there yeah so talk
to me about that people say feelings
come before thoughts no they don't if i
had a big plate of meat in front of you
what you think about that it comes
affects the feeling if you're a vegan
it's disgusting through a bodybuilder
it's great if i hold up a needle
it's the thought oh that's going to hurt
that's going to look 10 years younger
that's going to make me high i'm going
to have a tattoo
so we all believe that we can't control
our feelings when you get it right
thoughts control feelings the thought
comes before the feeling when you go
backwards again it's like so if
everything starts with a thought
it's easy to change your thoughts and to
change your feelings
and if you just keep changing your
thoughts what happens is it actually
starts to change your entire life so for
instance you might have a feeling um
what is it is it scared or is it excited
i don't know because they feel exactly
the same if you watch someone on a
roller coaster screaming are they scared
they're excited they don't even know but
you get to choose to go i'm excited i'm
feeling great or i'm terrified and i'm
falling apart and when you can start to
think
about what you're feeling and decide to
make it feel good i'm feeling challenged
i'm feeling all right about this i'm
feeling i can do it i've got this
tingling in my toes what is that terror
or excitement well i don't know but i'm
going to tell myself this excitement
then you're going to win at life all the
time because you get to be in control
saying i'm run by my feelings
i love that okay so knowing that how do
we then start to change that thought
pattern
well again everything comes the way you
feel about everything you see the way
you feel about something is down to two
things the pictures you make in your
head
and the words you say to yourself and
you could even cut that down and say the
way you feel is down to the words so we
use these amazing words terrifying it's
killing me i'm dying
um and you've got to change the words
that's challenging that's interesting
that's um fascinating
and stop saying it's killing me oh i
look a mess um i look terrible i've got
a memory like a sieve i'm going out of
my mind you think oh
well if i'm prepared to lie one i don't
just tell myself a better lie i look a
little dehydrated i look a little sleep
deprived and when you start to tell
yourself a better lie sort of saying i'm
terrified i'm challenged this is driving
me mad this is a
situation your whole life changes on a
dime because you realize oh i was lying
to myself and it felt real
so at least i'm gonna lie to myself in a
good way
and it will feel real and rule number
eight the last one before some very
special bonus clips is control your
thoughts
several years ago
i went to see a friend of mine
and he is considered by all means one of
the leading experts in the world on eeg
and brainwave frequencies and really
understanding
how our brain waves affect
how we feel and what we think about
and i went to this biocybernaut
institute to be able to recognize one
thing
number one was that my thoughts happened
randomly as a result of all of the years
of
learning experiencing listening to my
parents my teachers my brother my sister
and myself and as a result of that i
developed these neural patterns or brain
patterns that created these automatic
thoughts
some of them are positive some of them
were negative however what i learned at
the biocybernaut institute was that i
could control
my thoughts
now listen to me for just a moment if
you think about this
are you your brain
well the answer is no your brain is an
organ however your brain has billions of
cells and those cells connect and talk
to each other
every time you have a positive thought
you reinforce that thought pattern every
time you have a negative thought you
reinforce that thought pattern even
faster now the reason that your brain
does this is because it wants to protect
you from any real or imagined danger and
so a negative thought
is something that happens in the brain
that when it happens it reinforces
itself way faster than the positive
thought so one of the things that you
can do
is this
number one
is give your brain a command since
you're not your brain you can do this
and science has proven this you can give
your brain a command
to let you become aware of when you're
having a negative thought or even a
negative emotion
so the first spot or the first part that
you need to take control over is the
awareness part of what's happening
within you
then the next part is to recognize and
realize that you don't have to play into
a negative thought you don't have to let
it control you you can actually observe
your negative thought you can observe
even a negative emotion or an unpleasant
emotion and you can surrender to it and
what does that mean surrender doesn't
mean give up
surrender just means allow it to happen
without getting emotionally attached to
it
now if you become aware of an emotional
or mental thought that you have that's
negative and you surrender to it and
just allow it to flow by
you can use the word next
in order to give your brain a command to
move on to the next thought or to move
on to the next emotion and so as you're
aware of it as you surrender to it and
use the word next what i want you to do
next is refocus
your brain on what you want
the thought to be and the emotion to be
so you can choose a polar opposite
thought
that will really empower you
to have the right emotion and more
importantly will empower you to take
action around the new thought and
emotion so again the three steps are
become aware of your thoughts and your
emotions surrender to them by allowing
them to happen let them go by releasing
them by saying the word next and then
refocus your thoughts on what you want
to achieve what you want to take action
on and that way you'll start to be in
control of your thoughts your emotions
which will then drive the behaviors that
you want in order to achieve the goals
that are most important to you
the voice inside your head telling you
that you can't do something
is not your voice
it was put there
it was planted there
it was fertilized there by the people
around you by
your parents by your teachers by your
friends growing up by society it was put
there think about it when when you
were born when you were young
i don't know what your earliest memories
are but
you see kids everything is possible you
know like i'm going to be
an astronaut and i'm going to be an
architect at the same time and you know
my goal growing up i was going to be a
baseball player
play for the toronto blue jays my
hometown team and i was going to be a
police officer in the off season
so be professional baseball player
i love kelly gruber growing up third
baseman for the toronto blue jays and in
the off season
gonna be a police officer
because i love police officers like
everything is possible
everything is possible to kids and then
what happens
suddenly we start to get older and we
realize that
things aren't that way and we have to be
safe and we have to be practical and we
have to be smart
and that message gets drilled into us
and it could be your parents it could be
your friends it could be the school
system it could be the media it could be
society there's
lots of it
think about the people who are giving
you the advice
think about the people
that's why it's so valuable think about
the people telling you that you can't do
something
and how many of those people
genuinely
love their
life the people telling you you can't do
something how much of them actually love
their life
not a lot
right they don't
what gives them the authority
to tell you that you can't do it
some people will do it out of fear
it's love but fear right
maybe your mom's telling you you can't
do something
but she loves you probably
she's telling you because she wants you
to be happy she's telling you because
she's afraid she's telling you because
if you go off and do something that
doesn't work what's going to happen to
your life she's living from a place of
insecurity right that but it's love
and some people do it because of
jealousy
they try to live their dream they took
their shot and it didn't work out
and so now nobody else around them is
allowed to succeed instead of going and
taking a second shot they spend their
time trying to tear other people down
but either way
they're not happy
they never lived their life they never
chased after their goals they never
pursued their dreams
and now they're telling you that you
can't give her
most people are not happy
look at any
survey any study and or even just think
about it think about the people saying
no in your life are they does this
person actually love their life
probably you know
so why are we listening to them
and this is this is a problem because
most people don't love their lives right
and so you're surrounded by it's
everywhere it's it's in everything that
you're picking up and so it takes a
conscious effort to start to shift that
and this is why so many people when they
do learn when they do improve when
you've been on a personal development
personal growth journey when you learn
something you want to go help the people
around you right the first thing we want
to do the first instinct is to then
bring it to the people around us
because
we want the world to be better
right
so that voice is not yours that voice
was planted the mistake is seeking that
it's yours the mistake is thinking that
that insecure
voice inside your head is actually you
talking it's not you talking
that voice telling you that you suck
that you can't do this that someone like
you will never make it that's not you
that's not your real voice that is
your parents that is your school that is
society that is the media that's not
your voice that's what you've been
conditioned to believe
so how do we how do we start to change
it
um the goal of this video is not to be
you know giant conspiracy theory the
world's against us
but it's possible like how do you change
it how do you start to shift it well
we need to recognize one that that's not
your voice do you believe that that's
your voice because as long as you
believe that that's you
you stay small you stay stuck you stay
listening to it because
you're telling yourself that you can't
do it so step one is to recognize that
that is not actually your voice and if
you can do the deeper work to figure out
whose is it
whose voice is that is that your parents
is that your brothers is that your
schools is that that the media you're
consuming is that like who is it whose
voice is that and why do you still care
about listening to that voice like
that's some deeper work but if you
figure that out it'll allow you to stop
listening to it
step two is
to start to eliminate the things in your
life now that make that voice louder
maybe you're hanging around some people
who you shouldn't be friends with
anymore
you know maybe just because you're
friends with somebody in high school
doesn't mean you should still be their
friend now
you know maybe you've grown apart
and now it's time to get some new
friends
okay
do an audit of the people that you're
following on instagram and on youtube
and any social media and whatever you're
feeding your brain with do an audit and
think about are these people
which voice are they empowering
there's a great story about two wolves
you know
i'm gonna paraphrase it but there's two
wolves inside you one who wants the best
for you and one who wants to grow and
learn and improve and serve and share
and be courageous and the other wolf is
is scared and afraid and
keeping you small and stuck and insecure
and weak
and it goes well who which wolf wins
who's the wolf that ends up
carrying the day the answer is the one
that you feed
so if you feed the wolf all your
insecurities and fears and doubts then
that that wolf is going to win and you
will be
afraid and full of insecurities and
doubts and if you feed the wolf that
makes you feel bold and courageous and
powerful then you will become that too
so that process we need to recondition
ourselves
by changing the environment by being
around the people who are doing the
things that we want to do
so do that audit of the people you
follow on youtube on instagram and how
much of your time here's here's the test
is when you walk away from a video when
you walk away from
the app that you're on you feel better
about yourself you feel bolder more
courageous more powerful if you're
watching this video you know when you
watch my channel do you feel better
about yourself are you filled with more
belief ready to take on the day yes
great
hey i got more videos for you stay tuned
no i sincerely apologize
because that is not the goal but but
then if that is happening then then yes
unsubscribe for me and go follow some
other people
you know
and same thing for the people you follow
on instagram how many of those people
make you feel better do you leave
your phone feeling better about yourself
more courageous bald ready to start
today or did you just waste a whole
bunch of time and feel worse about
yourself great those people
unfollow them everybody who makes you
feel that way stop following them
and replace them because i guarantee you
that if you look for the light you'll
find the light
it's a good one
you know if you look for the light
you'll find the light there are people
on every social platform in every part
of the world who are
spreading kindness spreading belief
spreading hope spreading possibility
they exist everywhere
it's not common
it's not the default yet that's why lack
of belief i believe is the world's
number one problem because it's not
default yet but there are people
spreading the like
find them
be around them
hang out with them
collect them learn to collect good
people
it'll shift everything
so you've got a real important decision
to make
do you listen to your heart
the the
feeling that you want to do more and
serve more and help more and be more and
create more
or do you listen to that voice
that's not your voice
inside your head telling you all the
reasons why
you can't do it
it's a choice
you have to decide which wolf you're
going to feed
both wolves exist inside you
the insecure wolf
and the powerful wolf
and either one could win
it'll dramatically change your life
which one you feed
you just have to decide which one are
you going to feed today
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to defeat
the negativity in your head with lisa
bill you check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there yeah i actually do want to be the
number one sales person but i freaking
hate sending emails and so i only sent
30. so now the most amazing thing about
this process is it allows you to say